we are continuing to take calls at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 why don't we go to all I
don't know how about the six six one
area code caller from six six one or
maybe that's country code sixty six I
can't tell I guess we'll find out in a
second I tell us what what your name is
where you're calling from and what your
question is today
hey David my name is Brandon I'm
actually calling from California so I
just want to say hello on behalf of
everybody here in California that
supports you and we love your show and
we really appreciate it
think what you want Pat do but not just
in forever extolling you and all your
glories please but you know I hear I
hear a lot you know people say that the
Democrats need to change their message
but in my humble opinion David I just
think that this thing is a lot being a
black man and I can tell you that this
thing is about race a lot more than
people want to admit to a lot of people
Donald Trump is Custer's last band you
know and the reason why they have no
problem with him is because it was never
about him in the first place when Pat
Buchanan wrote that book the end of
white America or the fall of white
America or something like that he really
spoke to a lot of people and you can't
do polling because we know that if you
were to be polling it's not polite to
say that I feel like minorities are
taking over our country so a lot of
people would never do that anyway but I
just feel that until people realize that
this is much more about race than people
want to admit the Democrats trying to
change their message maybe it's going to
use a little bit of changing but I just
don't see that being the major problem
oh yeah but hold on a second Brandon
let's see if we can break this down into
its component parts so real quick when
you say okay it's about race you mean
that there are people supporting Donald
Trump because of hit because of his
racism yes I believe David that when
they say he tells it like it is what
they're saying is the things that come
out of his mouth about minorities they
were
we feel that way okay now any wielded
baby okay and walk me through the next
part which is which specific things that
Donald Trump has said about race do you
think racists are sort of reacting to I
think would he said it you know he
really you know when it comes to black
folks he never said anything particular
in about about black folks the things
that he said about Hispanics you know
and some of the things you know this
whole notion as you spoken about on your
show so elegantly of making America
great again is him saying that we need
to make our country why DNS we've seen
several times and in posters and
different things like that and that
resonates with a lot of white folks
whether they're going to openly say that
or not that resonates with them and they
feel like you know we want our country
back and so no matter what the Democrats
say because they look there and looked
at as the party of inclusiveness and
minorities and in you know being
politically correct it doesn't matter
what they say because they are held held
up as a as a people who are letting
minorities take over our country and
that's why they won't go along with the
Democrats so what you're kind of saying
is so that's it's not so much about
issues but that if you have a
fundamentally racist electorate then
they're going to go with the candidate
that they believe shares their beliefs
about race I think what you're saying is
interesting and I am someone who does
not believe obviously that racism has
been solved in the United States I think
there is no doubt there are racist
elements that support a Donald Trump
because of what they perceive to be his
sympathetic views about race to what
their beliefs were but that is a framing
that makes it sort of absolved Democrats
of any guilt whatsoever and there's a
lot of guilt to go around with the
Democrats Pat so while I agree with
Brandon that there are racist elements
that I mean we've seen a revitalization
of the the white right like never like
not for a very long time but to absolve
Democrats after all it was 77 thousand
votes in three states you can you can do
things differently and make up seventy
seven thousand votes in three states so
I think the Democrats are hugely guilty
of
the electoral failures they've had sure
I also think it's really a stretch to
call Donald Trump a racist but he
certainly does some dog whistling here
and there like his failure to condemn
the actions of the KKK or of David Duke
and the rest of them at least initially
saying I don't know who the guy is etc
listen Brennan I think you're thinking
of really important things but I worry
that you're going way too far in I mean
like for example Elizabeth Warren didn't
even get involved in the primary
even though Bernie Sanders aligned with
her views on so many issues and earlier
this week she said Democrats should be
talking about single-payer which is what
Bernie was doing that's a major mistake
that that has nothing to do with whether
racists vote for Trump or not you know
so I think what you're saying is
interesting I would not overstate the
importance of it oh I guess just in
closing I would just say that I
definitely wouldn't deny that Democrats
could do more but I think instead of
trying to change the message so much of
people that I'm not humble opinion I
don't feel are going to change their
mind I think they can do more to get
more of their own to the polls oh
absolutely
Oh Brendan looking I've been saying for
months now you can more easily get five
people to vote who didn't then you could
change the mind of one trumpet right
that's absolutely where the focus should
be all right Brendan thanks so much all
I appreciate it making a number of good
points although you know it starts to go
down the identity politics route which I
have I've been hesitant to go down in
the past because I think it is not
particularly the most useful